as many of you will know when Texas
joined the United States it looked like
this however a mere five years later it
had lost all of these lands which
nowadays formed parts of New Mexico
Oklahoma Kansas Colorado and even
Wyoming this massive loss of land raises
an obvious question why why did Texas
lose all this territory and why did the
Texans agree to it so in 1836 Texas won
its independence from Mexico after a
short war Mexico didn't really accept
this Independence but there was little
they could do about returning Texas to
the fold given all of the unofficial
help that the United States had given it
during the war the brand new Republic of
Texas claimed all of this territory but
only really had firm control over this
that doesn't mean Mexico controlled it
in fact most of it was controlled by the
Comanche tribe but nobody recognized
their claim to anything so after about a
decade of politically ignoring Texas the
U.S annexed it as a state the
overlapping claims of the US's newest
member in Mexico soon led to the
Mexican-American War which ended with
the U.S victory in Mexico losing all of
this so after winning a war for Texas's
disputed territory it would be fair to
assume that Texas would be given its
claimed lands but fun fact no instead
the federal government argued that the
Texan claim wasn't that strong and that
even though the land definitely wasn't
Mexican anymore it also wasn't Texan the
concern was that this new state was far
too large and thus would rule too much
power in the future and so was part of a
broader discussion on how to incorporate
America's new land several prominent
Senators but forward proposals on how to
divide Texas the first idea was that of
Missouri Senator Thomas Benton who
proposed that Texas be divided like this
with the Northern West going to the
federal government as part of the
territory of New Mexico and the rest
being divided into two states Texas and
Colorado this plan was much more about
keeping the free state slave state
balance in the union but it was also
unpopular with the Texans furthermore it
broke the rule of splitting States the
next plan was put forward by Senator
Henry Foote pushed for Texas to simply
be divided into two states Texas and the
brand new state of Jacinto this went
nowhere because again no splitting
States and if the Texans didn't like
those plans they really weren't going to
like that of Santa's John Bell this
would see this territory handed to New
Mexico and Texas divided into two new
States the land east of the Trinity
River would be the state of Texas and
the rest of the land would become the
Colorado territory that wasn't its
population got large enough that it
could be split into two new states which
Bell wanted to call Colorado and
Washington this proposal wasn't even
considered by the Texans thus the U.S
government needed to make sure that
Texas kept much more of its territory
and two ideas were put forward the first
was by Henry Clay who just did this
giving this land to New Mexico this was
rejected because it meant that this tiny
piece of land here would be seeded from
New Mexico to Texas which meant opening
a whole new can of worms and thus no in
the end it was Senator James Pierce that
settled the issue he put forward this
border which took this from Texas and
gave it to the federal government this
was acceptable to Congress because it
didn't require splitting the state of
Texas so long as you considered this to
be Texas and there is to be extra
territory that just happened to belong
to Texas so why did the Texans agree to
this when initially they just wanted to
keep all of their land well the answer
was money Texas has racked up a lot of
debt from its independence War and the
federal government promised to take on
that debt in return for Texas being
carved up another reason was that whilst
Texas declaim all of this it never
really held on to it and so what it was
given was still seen as extra and still
made Texas the largest state in the
Union as such both sides were mostly
happy and Texas took on the shape that
it has to this day I hope you enjoyed
this episode with a special thanks to my
patrons James bisonet Kelly moneymaker
kosher wolf cartwitska Alex Schwinn Andy
mcgehi Jerry lambdim rod D Martin AF
Firefly Marcus arsner why in hockey
Spencer Lightfoot Marvin Castle Captain
said okay Moon Yoon Winston K would miss
is it boogly Wiggly Maggie pascowski the
macquapo Gustav Swan calling Dr Howard
Dr Fine Dr Howard Coppertone shuwenin
spinning three plates words about books
podcast Jim Stromberg words about books
podcast and Charles the first